In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for October 4th, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hieromater, Peter of Capitolia.
Saint Peter came from the city of Capitolia in the diocese of Damascus.
He was married with three sons and was highly regarded for his wisdom and his good sense.
But, as the love of God was stronger within him than his love for his family, he separated
from his wife and became a monk.
He was subsequently ordained priest against his will by the bishop of Bostra.
When he was sixty, he became seriously ill and, fearing less the palm of martyrdom, escape
him, call together some eminent Muslims, ostensibly to give them charge of his last will
and testament.
But, really, to make an ardent confession of the Christian faith that ended in a vehement
denunciation of Islam.
Against all expectation, Peter got better.
And, desiring all the more to share the glory of the martyrs, he began to invade against
the error of the Muslims in the streets and squares of the city.
He was soon arrested and taken to Damascus to appear before the caliph Walid.
The Christians of Capitolia assembled and accompanied their priest along part of his way.
His fiery response to the caliph's questions left no doubt of his desire for martyrdom.
In sentencing him, the judge appointed a long and extremely cruel execution.
On the 10th of January, in the year 715, the holy martyr was taken back to Capitolia and
made the gazing stock of all the people above all of his son and daughter who were taken
out for the occasion from the cells where they had dwelt since their infancy and placed
in the first row of spectators.
The executioner tore out the saint's tongue to its root.
The next day he cut off a hand and a foot.
On the Sunday, in the presence of yet a greater crowd, the martyrs remaining hand and foot
were cut off.
He was blinded and fixed to a cross where he was pierced, thrice, with a spear, and so died.
Soldiers kept watch over his body for five days and then burnt it, throwing his ashes into
a nearby watercourse and even taking care to wash everything that could have touched
his holy relics so as to prevent the faithful from venerating them.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.